Worryingly described by entomologists and
arachnologists as a “not uncommon” occurrence
in certain parts of the globe, spider rain
can see anywhere from a few thousand to several
million spiders tumble from the sky in a given
area, seemingly out of nowhere.
So what causes it?
This is thanks to a rather interesting behaviour
exhibited by spiders known as ballooning,
which essentially involves an individual spider
climbing to a high point and then firing strands
of silk into the air, with the result being
the spider being carried away by the wind,
sometimes for many hundreds of miles.
Arachnologists are quick to point out that
countless spiders are probably flying around
over head at any particular time and that
they usually land without much fanfare and
go about their way.
Sometimes, though, many thousands or millions
of spiders will decide to balloon at the exact
same time, either because they’re a single
colony or because weather conditions force
them to.
In regards to the latter, on rare occasions
certain weather patterns can see the millions
of spiders floating through the air at any
given time being thrown to Earth simultaneously
at the same location.
Other known causes of spider rain are floods
and wildfires, which can prompt spiders to
flee en masse to escape what would otherwise
be their own demise, concerningly illustrating
that the age old “kill it with fire” way
of getting rid of spiders isn’t fool-proof.
As an example of the former flood trigger
phenomenon, in Pakistan following devastating
floods throughout the country in 2010, millions
of spiders noped out of there in a hurry via
mass ballooning.
While you’d expect the people of Pakistan
to be unhappy about having to deal with both
millions of spiders raining from the sky and
floods, the spiders were seen as a good thing
by most citizens because they ate all the
mosquitoes.
On that note, in addition to ensuring the
skies remain free of disease carrying insects,
wandering clouds of spiders also provide ample
food for birds and other creatures- a fact
that combined with spiders often being amongst
the first creatures to return to land devastated
by flood and fire (via ballooning and landing
back in the area), means that spider rain
is generally seen as being an overall beneficial
thing for nature via allowing these staples
of the food chain to quickly and widely disperse
themselves.
While you can observe individual spiders floating
about in most regions of the Earth, if you’re
wanting so see the specific phenomenon of
spider rain, where millions of spiders fall
from above en masse, your best bet is to live
in certain regions of Australia (because,
of course it’s Australia where this is most
common).
As New South Wales resident Keith Basterfield
states, “They fly through the sky and then
we see these falls of spiderwebs that look
almost as if it’s snowing.”
(You can see something of this effect here
in a video shot in Texas.)
Luckily for arachnophobes, mass ballooning
is a behaviour near exclusively observed in
smaller species of spider or ones that were
born very recently, as larger spiders are
simply too heavy to be carried along by typical
winds.
As a result, if you’re currently imagining
endless waves of tarantulas raining from the
sky, you can rest assured that if you ever
witness spider rain firsthand, at least you
won’t be dealing with big spiders, just
the little ones that can crawl around on you
without you even noticing they’re there…
This is also significant because most small
spiders don’t posses the ability to penetrate
human skin with their bites, even if they
are otherwise highly venomous.
Thus, for the most part, spider rain is harmless
(to humans).
However, the phenomenon can potentially damage
crops when millions of spiders all land in
the same location, with their subsequent webs
cutting the plants off from enough sunlight.
But I think the main point we want to drive
home to arachnophobes is that some spiders
can fly, and at any given time they may just
fall from the sky on top of your head…